this wet wet place is dry cold places
warm and warm places cold writes
Madeline Nash in her new book El Nino
unlocking the secrets of the master
weather maker the book chronicles the
system's erratic workings the science
surrounding it and its global reach and
spreading disease and threatening food
and water supplies the program runs 35
minutes well thank you all for being
here and for sharing your lunch hour
with me I'm sort of new at this this is
my first book so I'm not entirely clear
what I'm supposed to do up here but I
thought I might start out by reading a
little bit from it and then maybe
opening it it up to you for questions
that you might have as you've all no
doubt heard there appears to be an El
Nino in progress right now in the very
early stages the real question is when
it will lock in into a really coherent
basin-wide phenomenon in the equatorial
Pacific and that means when once it does
we can begin to predict some of the
effects that it might have here of
course the last time around it had quite
enough impact on California I actually
start out the book with an account of
what happened in this little town of rio
nido which is not very far to the north
of here along the Russian River and I'll
just maybe I'll just start out just
reading a little bit from from from how
I begin the book Gary lacombe was
exhausted for a long moment he just
stood at the top of his driveway and
stared into the stream of mocha colored
water swirling around his feet maybe we
can get the county to help us that his
wife Phyllis who was just as tired as he
was around that time from somewhere high
above came a series of sharp reports
that sounded a lot like rifle fire near
the top of the steep-sided canyon that
angled up behind the house gary figured
big trees must be fought falling
probably Douglas firs his shallow roots
had lost their grip on waterlogged soil
far and wide the scent that wafted from
those broken evergreen boughs invested
the air with a mysterious fragrance the
odd thing was there was no wind trees
usually fall Gary reflected when there's
when it was late on Friday night
februari 6 1998 in Northern California
the winter storm season was in full
swing and the LA comms and their
neighbors had been waging of non-stop
struggle to keep culverts and creek beds
clear of rocks mud and debris otherwise
these conduits would overflow and send
water spilling into yards driveways
houses and streets the past week had
been particularly trying with no more
than a day's break between storms of
unusual intensity as a result the
Russian River was threatening to sweep
over River Road the two-lane artery that
connects rio nido de santa rosa on the
east and granville on the west if the
river rose just another five feet Gary
and Phyllis well new road access to rio
nido could be cut off for days like most
other Californians Gary and Phyllis had
heard about the 1997-98 El Nino and
although they had not paid a great deal
of attention to the specifics they were
expecting the winter to be wet to them
wet meant that the cuoi gully behind
their house would fill with water
earning the nickname Phyllis had given
at white water to them went met the
Russian River into which white water
emptied was certain to overflow but
actually what the wet winter meant was a
landslide that was going to happen in in
just another hour or so and and cause
all manner of destruction in rio nido so
that story which is a late 20th century
story be starts the book and you know i
think that the landslide really that i
pick up a little bit later on to say
that what caused that the rio nido
landslide was not a single fluke storm
but a fluky season of storms the worst
winter storm seasons california had
experienced in 15 years and guess what
web 15 years before then was the 1992
1982-83 el nino the storm started in
december around the first of the year
there was a deceptive law but the law
last and during January Northern
California recorded to 20 days of rain
then during the first week of februari
the immense cyclonic systems rumbling
across the North Pacific powered up to
full bore and I'm sure you'll all
remember since you probably were living
here at the time that the week of the
rio nido landslide was very dramatic
before that people had been talking
about el nonsense and L no-show as if
this'll Nina was not going to do
anything at all and that week everybody
kind of shut up if you know that was the
week when the people at Stanford were
out in their kayaks and canoes and there
were about 300,000 people who were left
without electrical power big chunks of
the scenic highway that runs between
caramel and San Simeon we're tumbling
just tumbled down into the ocean and the
access to Big Sur was cut off until
about May and what was interesting of
course is that that storm really in
California had an echo over in Florida
because these these big storm systems
that go across the country don't just
hit California man that's that's how you
experience and that they go clear across
the country and there was a storm on
Groundhog Day that was just an epic
storm in Florida and they were all kinds
of of there were tornadoes there were
people in boats who were who were
swamped i think a crew of sword
fishermen had to be rescued by Coast
Guard helicopters and the gulf and the
gulf of mexico and but what was
interesting was not so much of these
storms were connected with each other
which of course people people kind of
knew but that they were all that these
storms were actually though the track
these storms took came out of this
disturbance in the equatorial Pacific I
mean which is very very far away and you
know over it was not just California
that was affected but the whole world
really was affected by this convulsion
in the tropical Pacific and you know
this is something that really we have
become aware of
only in the late 20th century I think
really since the since the El Nino of
1982-83 have we become aware of how
important El Nino and really the cycle
of which El Nino was apart how important
that is to our lives El Nino is the warm
side of us climate cycle that has only
recently been recognized as the most
important influence on monthly weather
weather patterns apart from the seasons
and climatologists have a term for the
meteorological slights of hand by which
El Nino turns dry places wet weight wet
places dry cold places warm and warm
places cold they call them
teleconnections literally long distance
links and by the end of the 20th century
these links had become to seem so strong
and so obvious that it was kind of hard
to remember that people everywhere had
not always known about El Nino and that
only toward the end of the 20th century
had they key acute into its power to
reconfigure the world on and so this
this sort of sets up the book I mean
I've got is really a double-stranded
narrative one one strand is about the
effects that El Nino has had on ordinary
people of like the leçons and reinita
but also like people who were living in
in East Africa in in on the border
between Somalia and and Kenya and who
also experienced they experienced
terrible flooding and which set up
conditions that led to the worst
outbreak of rift valley fever in in
history as far as we know I think about
90,000 people were made quite ill and
about a thousand people died and seventy
percent of the herds the the farm
animals that these people depend on for
a living were also wiped out and that
was a major economic hit to these people
you can kind of imagine what would
happen if your stock market portfolio or
your bank account was suddenly
diminished by seventy percent but so I
you know I talked about that the effects
on people that I also the other strand
is really the struggle that scientists
have had to understand this phenomenon
and
so it you know begins and they that that
part of the story begins in the 19th
century in colonial India and and in
Peru where it's I just had bits and
pieces of this overall puzzle but they
didn't really put it together as all
belonging to the same thing until about
the late 1960s so and then of course
that you know as science progresses of
the old questions are answered and new
questions come up and of course the new
questions now before us are the
questions about well what is the
relationship between El Nino and global
warming but I had a lot of fun with the
scientific parts of the book I mean I I
when I write about science I like to
think I'm writing for my mother so you
know I hope is I hope it is easy for
everybody to read and also the
scientists in the book are largely field
scientists they're the people who go out
into the world and have all these
incredible adventures so I kind of tells
tell about some of these adventures here
one of the one of the characters is
Lonnie Thompson who's a glaciologist at
Ohio State University and he is a he
pulled up in 1983 in the teeth of that
very powerful own El Nino and I score
that had a 1500 year long record of El
Ninos comings and goings and also it was
a climate record that was just
spectacular it showed El Nino it showed
longer-term cycles that you could call
el nino like and at la ninia like la
ninia being the cold side of the cycle
but anyway in chapter 3 and I'll just
read a little bit from from this to give
you a flavor of kind of what what Lonnie
Thompson is all about cuz start back
when he was just a very young man and
just starting out his career in science
and he's he's about to launch his first
expedition to the cal kaya ice cap in
southern Peru more than a quarter
century ago on a sun-drenched morning in
june nineteen seventy-four Lonnie
Thompson climbed into a battered old
truck and made the first of many
journeys from the bustling market town
of sick you Ani to a little village
called Sokka polka there in one of the
high valleys that cut through the
Peruvian Andes the road ended and the 26
year old graduate student from Ohio
State University emerged from the truck
to find himself standing on the edge of
a rock-strewn meadow stippled with
clumps of straw colored grass night was
only about an hour away and already the
day's warmth was beginning to fade some
distance from a small cluster of simple
stone houses Lonnie and his three
companions set up their tents ate a
simple dinner and tunneled into their
sleeping bags the next morning they were
hoping to get off to an early start they
plan to be out in the field for a total
of about six weeks and so had brought
with them a fairly hefty load of
supplies they had packs crammed with
camping equipment duffel bags filled
with ropes ice axes and crampons shovels
for cutting into ice they had burlap
sacks stuffed with potatoes onions cans
of meat and fruit packages of cereal
pots pans and other sundries it was far
too much for them to carry in on their
backs and so they had made arrangements
for pack horses to meet them but the
packhorses did not arrive at saga polka
the next morning nor did they arrive the
morning after that and to pass the time
Lonnie and the others began to explore
the surrounding countryside separately
and together they wandered along this
bet splashing waters of the Saco River
fanned out across slipping grasslands
browse by mixed herds of alpaca and
sheep and climbed some of the rocky
prominences that stood setting on above
the valley it was on top of one such
prominence as he drew his breath and
ragged gasp that Lonnie caught his first
glimpse of the kakaya icecap broad and
very nearly flat but with steeply angled
sides the asset the ice cap resembled a
dazzling white coverlet thrown over a
slightly rumpled bed only in this case
the coverlet measured 22 square miles
and spread across an eighteen thousand
seven hundred foot high plateau framed
by jagged snow-clad peaks even at a
distance it seemed enormous at that
moment Lonnie did not realize it but he
would spend the nest
next decade of his life wrestling with
that I as ice cap with calc ayahs
remoteness its ruggedness and above all
its height it would be an epic match won
the denmarks Willie Dan's guard one of
the Titans in the exploding field of
papalia climate ology predicted Lonnie
would lose kal kya was too high for
human stands guard said but all that lay
ahead as did the El Nino that would
change the intellectual landscape of
climate science is profoundly as the
rise of the andean court elara had
altered the topography of peru as Lonnie
would come to appreciate these two
upheavals were not as unrelated as they
might seem it was the rise of the
court'll era that helped establish the
weather patterns are profoundly
disrupted by El Nino and ensured that a
record of those disruptions would be
preserved in calc ayahs ice in 1974
however Lonnie had not yet made the
connection between kal kya and El Nino
in fact prior to making that fateful
trip to brew he had not even heard of El
Nino and certainly he had no abiding
interest in the tropics he was a
glaciologist and along with virtually
everyone else in the field he shared an
unexamined belief that the torrid mix
midsection of the world was
climatologically speaking inert the
action it was all but universally
assumed lay in the polar regions in the
dramatic expansions and contractions of
the great ice sheets whose impressive
remnants continued to involve envelop
the Earth's highest latitudes and
razor-edged cold and of course this
whole perception of the tropics has
changed I I think it's changed largely
because because of El Nino really and we
see El Ninos power to affect the whole
world and so toward the end of the book
I kind of get into wit where scientists
are going with this whole idea now and
we part of it is really related very
much to the puzzle that chases us now
which is global warming really the idea
is as the earth warms how well the
climate system respond and what we know
about this region of the tropical
Pacific is that the atmosphere and ocean
are couples very tightly together that's
what
uses el nino but there are other ways in
which this very tightly coupled system
could produce el nino type things or you
no longer scale changes that could also
be very dramatic and very and very much
of concern to us and so I think
increasingly people are looking at this
region as perhaps key to the puzzle of
how the earth might actually respond to
the forcing that we are now beginning to
apply through increase increases in
greenhouse gases I actually went to
quell kya with with Lonnie I I did a lot
of traveling for the book and that was
that made a lot of fun i went to rio
nido several times a lot it's a
beautiful area I also went to Australia
I went to Borneo the island of Borneo
and spent some time in east kalimantan
which you perhaps remember was the site
of these just enormous fires wildfires
raged for months at a time couldn't
nobody could put them out i say
wildfires though of course most of them
were sent by people who were use fire as
a land clearing tool it's cheaper than a
bunch of bulldozers and just as
effective and maybe more so but I went
to Cal Cal yo with Lana and I remember
that was sort of the last thing I did
what I did for the book and I remember
going home and sort of and telling my
husband that well I'm gonna go to the
top of kal kya eighteen thousand seven
hundred feet high ice cap in southern
Peru I'm gonna climb it and he said
you're going to do what and so actually
he he's in the back of the room and he
had to the good the good sense to think
that it would be a good idea if we went
into La Paz first and spent some time at
altitude before tackling the the ice cap
so we did that for about a week and I
you know I think I that that is a
spectacular area and I don't know if any
of you in the audience or writers but I
had the feeling at that moment that I
had a lot of pieces of the book and I in
place but
I kept trying build the arch the arch
just wouldn't stay up and kal kya was
really the Keystone for me for the book
so when I dragged my aging 58 year old
body to the top of that ice camp I felt
I really an immense an immense sense of
satisfaction then and the chapter 11
kind of tells that's the yet that last
chapter it does tell tell the story of
that journey and it tells a story of I
don't know how much time I have should I
should I should I go ahead and I could
could read a little bit from from that
too I won't read the whole section I'll
kind of skip around back to kill kya it
is August in the year 2000 Lonnie
Thompson is standing on the veranda of a
remote field station that belongs to the
regional utility company electro Peru in
the foreground wind troubles of waters
of a small lake that lies behind a low
hydropower dam in the background the
Setting Sun lays a fleeting touch and
the broad white shoulders of the
calcaneus ice cap then it happens the
quarry Calais glacier of the ice caps
edge catches the last rays of light and
rims over with glistening gold in case
you aw says Lonnie the name corey
callous means gilded goblet at times
like this it is easy to imagine that
some mountain God is in fact lifting
Corey Collis to his lips and drinking in
its exotic elixir the moment passes
Venus Rises in the cobalt sky heralding
the onset of evening below the ice camp
the world dissolves into gloom with
astonishing with rapidity the eye the
air sheds its warmth and with it the
capacity to hold moisture so that the
simple act of breathing produces
streamers are missed Lonnie and his
companions retreat indoors still wearing
their jackets they huddle around a
simple wooden table and sup on soup and
bread then they turn in piling on thick
layers of blankets and an elevation of
16,000 feet nighttime temperatures can
be relied upon to drop below freezing
the next morning as the Sun starts a
slow pan across frost Club grass Monty
ventures out to the veranda again
and this time he appears at the icecap
through a pair of binoculars kal kya
surface he can immediately see is no
longer smooth but ripples with waving
indentations equally disturbing and the
black fingers of rock intruding into the
ice and though Lani can't see them he
knows that lakes are nibbling at the
edges from looking at satellite images
Lonnie thinks that a lake may have
formed near the top of the ice cap as
well and if that is indeed happened then
the ice camp could dwindle into
nothingness in an alarmingly short
period of time that's because unlike
snow and ice water unbalanced does not
reflect solar energy but absorbs it a
lake in the middle of an ice cap is like
a space headed heater in the middle of
an igloo after breakfast Bonnie and the
others pile into two does covered
four-wheel-drive trucks and head for the
village of fun iya a cluster of
whitewashed buildings that lies on route
everyone in the village it seems has
turned out in greeting and for a long
while a few dozen people just stand
there staring quizzically at their
visitors the men are clad and woolen
ponchos and cholos woolen cats caps
knitted an intricate geometric designs
the women are wearing multiple skirts
dyed bright primary colors and tall top
hats fashioned from soft ground felt
behind their backs their glossy black
hair falls to their waist and needed
neatly pelt planted braids and at fine
I'll just sort of skip through this a
little bit we have to the other the
expedition wants to buy some meat and
that sounds just fine until the source
of the meat a big ol you with a noble
head and a curly coat of wool is trotted
out for closer inspection do we have a
choice lying wonders the sheep's had a
University of Kentucky climatologist
Keith Mountain replies these folks need
the meat they're going to whack the
sheet anyway we can take we can just
take a little part of the wet thing
Lonnie gives his assent there by sealing
the fate of the sheep and everyone piles
back into the trucks again I'm just glad
Regina isn't here Lonnie says referring
to his vegetarian daughter anyway so
from
there we we get out of the truck and the
trucks and then we start hiking across
this incredible landscape it's just it's
just really beautiful by now Lonnie has
so thoroughly memorized the route that
he has no need of a map he walks slowly
and methodically across a rock-strewn
grassland his hills and valleys undulate
like standing waves in the notion things
have changed since the nineteen
eighty-three kal kya expedition he
reflects for one thing because the road
has been lengthened the hike into the
icecap no longer takes two days someone
in modestly good shape which I was at
the time can make it in about five or so
hours though not without gasping for
oxygen and the progressively thinning
hair this is a humanized landscape it
has been for several thousand years ever
since people domesticated the Yama and
nepal pakka that thrive in these high
mountain pastures as one walks one
encounters isolated stone houses with
animal Corral's one stumbles across
little dams and canals built to create
artificial marshlands one of the most
like plants that grow in these moniez
marshlands contains high concentrations
of silica alpaca use it as a kind of
emery board to foul down their
ever-growing teeth at last the camp at
the base of the ice cap comes into view
there between twin moraines the kitchen
Lonnie and his colleagues constructed
out of boulders so long ago these
boulders come from the Little Ice Age
Lonnie says they marked the place where
a keg Cal kaya's terminal glaciers ended
back around 1800 there are older Marines
farther down the bear mute witness to
even more dramatic advances of ice in
the early 1970s when Lonnie first saw
kal kya greenhouse warming had not
become the overriding concern it is
today at the time he reflects a lot of
people were worried about the onset of a
new ice age temperatures are becoming
down since the 1950s I even remember
covers of magazines showing palm trees
with ice on them I remember those too
it's now dusk the wind is growing
sharper and colder in the distance
lightning flashes and thumb
Thunder rumbles storm clouds swirl
around the formidable peak of Nevada
awesome gaudy which is the third highest
peak in Peru as quickly as possible the
members of the expedition unpack their
gear and pitch their tents they stretch
a bright blue tarp over the boulder
kitchen and beneath it Keith met
Mountain weeps whips together a dinner
it's a stew of sorts made by combining
freeze-dried soup with freeze-dried
vegetables and chunks of can meet
everyone is tired almost too tired to
eat under the blue tarp candles flicker
above it the ice cap looms like the
negative shadow of night under the blue
tarvis is sort of over a succession of
nights Lonnie and everybody else sort of
has a series of discussions really that
link the past to the future and we're
kind of trying to look out into the 21st
century and and you know understand more
about where the journey to understand El
Nino has brought us brought us all and
of course in the background of that
discussion is this the mega problem of
global warming and so anyway I'll quit
now and any questions I'd be happy to
answer and if I can this the one I don't
know go ahead magazine you could
recommend about meteorology that would
help people like me who have not a
scientist a layperson like I know about
scientific american but are there any
magazines there's a turret I like
weather wise I think weather wise is a
great magazine I don't know if do you
know that I would ok weather wise and
eyes this kind of a cool one um um I
think that's really I mean there it
depends on whether how much you they're
certainly the meteorological journals
there I think it helps when I read a
book like your is that I'm able to
follow it better and then keep up with
what's actually going on and then it
just makes it easier pepper Betty I
think weather-wise doesn't really
weather-wise ok thank you some friends
of mine actually write for it all right
thank you very much hey um do you had a
question back there
c6 the climate was warm enough in
England to grow orange trees but today
it's too cold to grow orange trees
that's nine hundred and thirty-six years
ago which is contrary to this philosophy
of grow a woman well isn't I don't I
don't really see it as contrary I do get
in the book I do get into these long in
fact the calcanei score and the ice
cores that Lonnie Thompson has gathered
since then actually speak to these
long-term longer-term cycles in the
climate they are there there you know
what what L mean basically the swaying
back and forth that you see in El Nino
when this and why I think it's so
important it's something the climate
likes to do and it does it on it appears
to do it on all different timescales it
appears to do it on de kadel time scales
on hundred-year timescales you know two
or three hundred years so you were
talking about the Medieval Warm Period
and of course there was a little ice age
later on and even before the Medieval
Warm Period there's something called the
Roman warm period and so I don't see
these two things as being opposed at all
I mean I think that the Pete the
scientist in this to my talk about in
this book are really trying to
understand the natural system because
the natural system is very powerful and
we are we are interacting with that
natural system so whatever we're doing
is you know is it is is imposed on top
of a system that is has for a very long
time been operating quite independently
of us and is very very powerful we are
now six billion people strong worldwide
and you know it's clear to me that we
are in currently in a very very warm
period now one can argue i think over
well you know how much of it is due to
what we're doing is any of it do at this
point to what we're doing and you know i
don't think anyone can answer those
questions definitively I however you
know I think if you if you say
okay it's all natural I mean I I do kind
of play with this call question in the
book of is it natural or not and how
would we know I think it's a very
important question but say it is all
natural well I don't necessarily think
that is good news what that means is
that we're imprinting on top of us of a
system that is in a very warm state
anyway for a treat for its own reasons
which which means that what we're doing
could have could potentially have
impacts beyond what we could even even
imagine at this time so I you know I
don't I don't really see you know the
mean I think that understanding the
natural system is extremely important um
I think what worries what worries me is
and what worries a lot of the scientists
that that I that I've never related with
over over the course of doing this book
is the climate system is a very
complicated system that is capable of
dramatic nonlinear responses El Nino
shows you that you can change the the
mode of operation of the system in an
almost in an instant I won't say it's
not like in a second but it happens very
very quickly and all you and it happens
you know within we can watch this we
watch this unfold before our eyes of
every two to seven years and so you know
you you watch El Nino and you think well
you know people have been talking about
well rapid climate changes being a
problem under a global warming scenario
well that makes it sounds like sound
like rapid climate changes something
that well I mean it's sort of like this
fictitious thing well it isn't it's the
way the climate system operates so I've
you know I don't I don't want to pretend
to to give answers as to what you know
what we should do about about global
warming I think that that deserves a in
about you know greenhouse gases I
that deserves a serious discussion I
think it's you know what to do about
about about such an issues given the
presence of uncertainties is something
that reasonable people can certainly
disagree about and so forth I don't
think we're having that debate yet I
think we're we're having a debate about
way this sort of sounds to me like oh
the earth is warming no it's not the
earth is warming no it's not well it is
warming and then and the question is you
know why to what extent are we are we
responsible how much of an effect are we
going to have and given but given the
the possibility that we could have more
effect than we'd like to have what at
this point would be prudent of us to do
you know to do and you know I don't know
I mean I think that's a whole different
discussion and I didn't go there I just
I just raised some of those questions I
guess so yep generate consensus is there
a consensus among meteorologist today
that this early developing El Nino is
inexorably on its way to a full
development Turner well don't you know
the fun thing about El Nino is I'm a
journalist by background and so all
journalists like man bites dog stories
that's something that's not supposed to
happen right well throughout all these
years El Nino has been biting scientist
it's always been doing something
surprising so you know I think you're
most scientists or are you know
cognizant of that and so you won't find
anybody making an absolute definitive
statement that that that this is
definitely going to happen I think what
is new and the reason i would give this
particular event
some credibility is the fact that since
1982-83 we've installed this incredible
ox observation system in the both in the
ocean and up in space so that one
actually knows the that you one can see
how much heat there has built up in the
western basin of the equatorial pacific
and there's you know there's a huge big
blob of red stuff as means it's pretty
warm water there and that of course is
the that's the energy source that that
drives an El Nino through and then on
the eastern sector one sees the very
definite warming off the coast of Peru
right now peru and ecuador in fact
Ecuador has had torrential rainfall
right now the ant ivetta off the coast
of peru are becoming scarce of becoming
of Galapagos the boobies have all gone
away they eat and travail de they're not
there anymore so there is sort of this
sort of mini kind of regional El Nino
going on down there now I think the real
question is when is it's going to walk
in when is the whole of the of the
eastern Basin of the equatorial Pacific
going to turn really warm and you know I
think what people at the center for
climate prediction are saying is that
they're saying it could be anywhere
between the next three to nine months
and the next two months though are going
to be the critical months the natural
cycle the night in the natural way of
things this sector of the ocean is
trying to cool right now it would like
to cool but there is this sort of other
influence the the el nino i would like
to have an el nino now please influence
and so these over the next two months
these two these two kind of counter
countervailing influences are going to
kind of duke it out and so it could
happen you know the last time around of
course I mean no to El Ninos are ever
alike in the same sense that no two
storms are ever exactly alike so
get you know you this is not going to be
exactly like 1997-98 it's not um in
terms of its timing it's about four
years since um since the last one that's
and that's perfectly that's not abnormal
at all I guess the real question is you
know how strong is it going to be and I
mean I can't tell you that either so I
think once we know we know that there is
an El Nino once we get an idea of how
strong it is then one can begin to to
make some predictions that might be
helpful in terms of planning for for
certain kinds of things that are more
likely to happen it's you know it's I
think it's hard for people to deal with
probability i mean i don't know why cuz
so many people go to Las Vegas to gamble
you think that they have a better sense
of probabilities but of course the fact
do you mean like the last time around in
California that you know their
prediction was in fact I tell the story
the scientist who made that prediction
about California going to be very rainy
and the time of course people were
saying oh well be sometimes El Ninos
bring drought to California and that can
certainly happen I mean it's not a
hundred percent these predictions are
simply being that the it's playing with
you know with some some loaded dice and
you just get snake eyes more often than
you would expect and that doesn't mean
you don't you're not going to get the
other so anyway
this set it okay Madeline Nash is a
former science correspondent for Time
magazine and author of El Nino unlocking
the secrets of the master weather maker
it's published by Warner box visit TW
bookmark com for more information